hi I'm Christopher hin and today we're
going to talk about the way I pin and
one of the horrible horrible things I
think that happens in pinning all of the
time that we actually generally don't
even think about in iido and I think we
really should think about it because
it's a really important thing um and I
think it's a mistake that everyone makes
all the time I made it for years until
for myself I really started breaking
down how pins work in iido and what the
goals are in the pins and how to most
efficiently apply the pin so I'm GNA
call Josh over here and Maya today and
we're going to go to work Josh
Maya all right okay so uh actually we're
gonna start with Josh little movie Magic
and uh I'm going to talk about the
pinning I'm going to talk about some
basics of pinning and then I'm going to
talk about what I think is the worst
mistake I see consistantly in the
sitting pins um and I'm only going to
cover sitting pins right now so there
are a myriad of standup pins maybe we
put that in another video but uh I want
to talk about just a tiny bit about the
taked down and then about the pen so in
iido generally we're going to be taking
down from the arm whether that's an EO
or a Niko or a Yono or a goo um or roio
we're probably going to be using this if
we get him backwards like this we're
probably this is probably a Sano pin
right so it could be either and this is
called UD which just means arm pin Tak
down um and this is a yaku and this is
regular UD O say right so I'm on this
side okay now either way I'm going to
always drop my inside knee first and my
inside knee is going to be behind Josh
right so let's say I'm doing a standard
old EO pin here right okay I'm going to
take Josh down my inside leg is going to
drive Josh down and Josh needs to be
ahead of me so meaning Josh is down now
and my knee's down right after that
right so I drive Josh down and then my
knee goes down if I do this the opposite
I have no power right so if Josh is up
and I'm down my weight is already all on
the ground right so whatever weight I
have you know if I weighed 110 lb then
that would be I'd be lacking 110 PB if I
weigh 200 lb I'm lacking 200 lb right so
my my pen would be significantly less
powerful if I put my knee down before I
drive him down so as you're bring him
down always drive him down ahead of your
knee so Josh's shoulder locks down
before my knee locks down okay now when
I'm here I want to make sure his
shoulder is secured 100% to the mat
right so I am in this upright position
driving his shoulder down as much as I
can I want that shoulder locked down and
I would like his arm in a straight
position right now okay now depending on
what take down will depend on the set of
holds I go into but the next thing is to
lever my knee over towards Josh's head
right so I'm going to lever my knee this
way and that's where we're going to
start to get our pin now um try not to
have your foot too far away from your
knee as you do this right so you really
don't want this you're lacking power if
you're in this position bring your foot
over and that'll give you a lot more
power to drive his um arm over okay so
what I'm trying to do is I've got his
shoulder locked down and I'm Levering
his arm this way to get him to go okay
now we're going to start to talk about
that horrible thing I was talking about
now Josh right now like most of us at a
certain point in time you start to lack
a little bit of flexibility with your
arms behind you right so you won't see
this in children or real flexible people
but right about here is where Josh is
tapping now he's tapping because his
shoulder is totally tight right now so
if I were to try to go into the full
variation of this pin with Josh right
now and I and I did it all the way
either his shoulder would go out of
socket or I have to go into a stupid
position which means I go like this or
something right and I try to pin now I
see Iko people pinning like this a lot
with people with tight shoulders and
this is a horrible idea I just put
myself into a weaker position just
because I need to accommodate the
shoulder so the form of this pin is
being executed but actually the reason
for the form is not being executed so
right now I'm weak I've got really no
ability to hold Josh down Josh I took a
lot of pressure out of Josh's shoulders
so I could come this way right so if I
didn't do this his shoulder would have
popped when I did this right so it'd
probably dislocate if I kept driving his
hand come up quick if I just keep
driving my pressure down right so let's
look at Maya movie Magic so this is Maya
now so if we use Maya Maya's got a lot
more flexibility with her arms behind
her now in order to pin I can pin
perfectly straight so see how my spine's
way straight my shoulders still locked
down she's got all this flexibility and
then I drop down here I secure her hand
however it is I'm going to secure
depending on the pin I'm doing I drop to
her elbow depending again on the pin I'm
doing and I lock her all the way down
then the arm goes up I remove the rest
of the slack now you see her foot just
come up her foot came up because this
got tight right now and then I lean
forward a little bit now here's another
pin problem you see the opposite of this
one which is really a horrible way to
pin is if they're flexible like Maya is
and they just from right here start to
lean forward look how far over I can go
before Maya's really starting to feel
the pin right I'm really leaned over too
far but if I take her arm up towards her
head so I'm going this direction towards
her head I tighten that up now you see
as she moved her foot if I kept going
this way that would probably tap her
right now but I can get even more by
leaning into her just a little bit right
so when you have someone who's really
really flexible there arm can go pretty
far this way as long as it's in a down
position now the further down I bring
her arm her hand like towards her legs
then she her arm can go even further
over but the further I take her arm up
over her head you see how her hand just
came up it's CU it's getting tight right
now and I start to take it over now it's
much much tighter now if you have
someone like Gumby right and this was
Maya probably about five years ago right
so uh as we age all of us and it happens
relatively quickly start losing
flexibility behind us and it's because
we build bigger muscles in front of us
so we lose that flexibility behind us so
if you have someone who's really like
Gumby they might still be even with the
arm really far up they might be able to
to not tap so in that case what we do is
we bend the elbow here and we crank the
hand towards the head right so what that
looks like let me have you turn this way
just a little bit okay so what that
looks like is as I'm here I pull that
elbow in tight to me like this and I
continue the hand up now you see how
quick she moved it's cuz it's got really
tight really really fast I can continue
that hand up here and it would be just
like you would see a cur or a hammer
lock something like that from a
grappling style where I'm moving the
hand up and that really really cranks
into the shoulder really really tight so
I've removed a lot more slack by bending
this arm like that so again the process
is always drop the inside knee make sure
the shoulders locked down then drop this
leg and put the the arm along your body
now as you do that this is all
tightening so it's just got super super
tight secure the arm then drop straight
down up and over right when you get to
that nice tight spot you know now if I
did this in one really fast motion I'd
probably damage that shoulder if she's
like Gumby and I'm going to do a pin
kind of bad so you can see if she's like
Gumby and I'm way over here and she's
still not tapping then I'm going to bend
that elbow lock it to me and I'm going
to turn the hand up now when I do that
after I bend the elbow I'm just trying
to get her hand to go to her head like
this right everyone will tap from this
right I mean maybe maybe there's some
contortionists who wouldn't but 99% of
people will tap from this right I've
taken like you know little super
flexible gymnast 11-year-old girls and
you're able to do this because this
takes all all the stretch out of that
arm right so even a really flexible
person you're going to get them like
that okay so um the basic idea of this
is whenever I'm doing a pen whether it's
from a regular UDA or a Gak UD I drop
the inside knee first when I'm doing
that I make sure that their shoulder
precedes my knee so my knee doesn't make
contact till the shoulders already hit
if someone's really lacking flexibility
that might be enough to get them to tap
right then in there then if I can't get
them to tap there I lock it in I use my
leg to drive their arm forward most
adults will start to tap in that range
Okay then if that doesn't work I
continue with the leg towards the head
and secure the arm along my body 90% of
full adults are going to B are going to
tap at this point now if that doesn't
work I'm going to bend the elbow and
crank the hand towards the head and then
that will get probably 99.9% of people
to tap because it just takes all the
slack out of the arm entirely so that's
the basic process depending on what pen
you're using there are slight variations
on each of those depending on if it's a
Niko pin or a goo pin or a Sano pin but
all of them have that same exact
structure right so that structure will
be consistent if you can Master this
structure your pins will go through the
roof right away so your pins will get
better
immediately irregardless of the or
regardless regardless of the um the
detail of that pin right so the Sano
adds a little more wrist twisting in it
the Niko adds a little more elbow
emphasis in it the rokio adds elbow
wrist emphasis um so different ones
require or have slightly different
emphasis but that is the main structure
of all of them all right so I hope you
found this useful I'm Christopher hin
that's Joshua th and my salon McDaniels
right here oh look she gave you a thumbs
up see I see this all the time but you
guys never get to see that so she's
right here yeah it's the ghost he's
manned the cameras before when you
weren't here all right we'll see you
guys in the next
video hey I'm Christopher hin so if you
made it all the way through this video
chances are you kind of liked the way I
presented stuff or were so irritated by
it that you wanted to watch more of it
so I have a patreon page maybe that's
just for you you should check it out
there are literally hundreds of videos
on that patreon page I've been making
videos for patreon since I think 2020 or
2021 uh and I've been making somewhere
between two and five a week so there are
tons of videos up over there so you
might want to check that out it's
patreon.com Christopher Hine uh hope to
see you there
[Music]